[Applause]
got to VidCon before the 7120 other
attendees so I could see the expo hall
and the dftba booth in the places where
you can get food and the bouncy castle
and also so I could see the stage before
standing on it in front of a lot of
people are you feeling right now
I have to pee all right we're ready it's
at only about 98% of the time those are
the last words you say to me before we
go on stage
ah
so VidCon was pretty amazing I mean you
performed a lot with Felicia Day and
George Watsky in front of several
thousand people Megan Tanja sang a song
about my book
we met loads of nerdfighters and had the
chance to talk about educational video
and watch a Gregory Brother hula hoop
Orly Hank ever hears something at VidCon
Phil's my nerdy heart with joy and this
year it was taking an hour away from the
craziness to discuss the Monty Hall
problem with vihart brady and derek
during which time i discovered that if
you have two children and both are born
on a weekend and one of them is a boy
born on a saturday the other is most
likely a girl that really blew my mind
although not as much as watching several
thousand people join you in singing a
song about particle physics
French the freaking llama hexa there you
go my VidCon was all about math and
physics but other people had other
vidcon's more on that in a second as you
can possibly tell from the view in the
mirror I am on vacation with the yetis
family which you couldn't tell from the
view in the mirror it's quite nice out
there Hank and you know what summer time
at the beach means it means it's time to
slather on the SPF 50 and read some
great literature together so here in the
nerdfighter book club we're reading
Fahrenheit 451 or as I call it when I'm
trying to remember how to spell
Fahrenheit far in height 451 your first
reading assignment is to finish part one
of the book the hearth and the
salamander by next Tuesday hold on I'm
going to build a tripod better so wait
we're both going to read Fahrenheit 451
and we're both going to make videos
about it and our readings will probably
be very different and that will allow us
as a community to discuss how best to
read why we read what we find fulfilling
about reading I'm very excited about
this
so think ultimately what I love about
reading together is precisely what I
love about VidCon you started VidCon but
we all make it happen together just as
Bradbury wrote his novel but it doesn't
become real until we read it of course
even a mid shared experience we're still
alone like I said earlier my VidCon was
unique and each reading of every book is
unique but what a comfort it is to share
readings and experiences how lucky we
are when we get to be alone together
thank thank you for starting VidCon and
a huge thanks to Carver and Jenny and
Monica and Jojo and all the volunteers
who made it actually happen
dftba I will see you on Friday
ha wait ice cream why does everyone look
at me like this a nice cream